because i'm gonna go off on this one all
right we got the story about the falcon
and the winter soldier you may have seen
it's a new disney plus
show and get well go broke baby because
the last rumor report
we were covering is that there was this
scene in the show
it's the falcon and the winter soldier
from the avengers movies they're walking
down the street and they're arguing and
it's the falcons a black dude and the
winter soldier's white dude
some cops pull up out of nowhere and
they walk up to bucky the white guy and
they're like
is everything okay sir and he's like
yeah it's fine is this man giving you
trouble and they're like
what are you talking about and then sam
is like what's going on and the cops are
like sir sir calm down
and then bucky's like don't you know who
this is and the cops were like oh
man oops it was the avenger oh geez
according to the rumor
this obvious black lives matter
narrative
soured a bunch of people who turned the
show off and stopped watching
i don't know if that's true or not
that's a rumor but apparently we're
hearing a lot i'm seeing a lot of posts
on twitter from people who are like i
just couldn't do it it's so
over the top and absurd had nothing to
do with the plot at all literally it was
like
they're like we got to stop these super
soldiers man and the cops pull up and
they're like hold on there sir we're
going to do a racism it's like
it had nothing to do with the show right
all right well
we got a new one for you captain america
is an incel
oh here we go baby the rap says in cell
captain america is so perfect
we know it's wrong to enjoy the whiny
and murderous john walker on the falcon
winter soldier
but it feels so right i tweeted the
wokeness
in the falcon and in fact the falcon in
which soldier is getting too
thick to be enjoyable because the latest
episode was like
uh zemo who's the bad guy is like this
lady is a super soldier and now she will
be a spoiler alert sorry i guess so if
yeah if you're not ready for this
spoiler alert
anyway i'll continue the the anti-hero
guy zemo he says
she will become a supremacist now that
she has super soldier you know serum in
her veins or whatever
and it was like the idea was basically
that people who gain
power crave it and then start believing
that they're the only ones who should
have power
who can solve the problems and he's like
the nazis believed it the avengers
believe it
and now you've got this rogue group of
you know extremists globalist leftists
who kill innocent people to get their
way
the rep says let me just read some this
for you john walker
aka the new captain america showed us
his true self on the
falcon with her soldier this week in
more ways than one the new cap has
struggled to feel like he belongs
in a world full of gods and aliens and
super soldiers and for good reason
he's just a regular soldier the us
government decided to name the new
captain america without consulting
so far as we know any current mcu heroes
he hasn't been trained to fight these
battles
so of course he's going to get whooped
and so we have this new captain america
he's just trash at his job he's
embarrassed and certainly looks like he
hasn't been sleeping because of his
frustration at being sidelined by actual
heroes
there's an easy remedy to the issue
partner up with sam and bucky and follow
their lead
but this toxic masculinity captain
america can't do that
he's freaking captain america he's
supposed to be the lead he can't take
orders
from these sidekicks even though they're
better than him at everything
even though they actually fought
superhuman folks and worse before
even though they have some idea how to
operate freely like this and john walker
doesn't the show is called the falcon
and winter soldier
but this guy thinks it should be the
captain america show for most the
episode
the new captain america is a huge clown
seething with rage about his numerous
inadequacies
like some kind of message board in cell
wondering when we're finally going to
talk about men's rights
and then he gets a hold of the final
vial of super soldier's serum
and he puts that stuff in his body and
he graduates to captain clown
they say way back in the first avenger
captain america the creator
of the original serum said that it
amplifies everything that is inside good
becomes great bad becomes worse
steve rogers was good becomes great and
it looks like john walker is the other
one
it's kind of a strange arc for john he
was originally presented as idealistic
and excited to help
but he so quickly went from that to
being a tool without much much of a
de-evolution
he just he was just he just was a good
guy and then he was yelling at the real
superheroes for being so good at their
jobs
that they're making him look bad but i
like where we ended up
i like seeing this trash person angrily
beat down bad guys because he hates them
so much
and then tarnish the uniform in the
shield by beating a guy to death in
front of a crowd
of people to get revenge for his injured
or dead partner
it's disgusting and it felt so
incredibly wrong and it was absolutely a
thrill to watch
i'd love for blah blah blah okay you get
the point all right i'm gonna i'm gonna
thoroughly give this a hop and a
debunking
i'm actually interested to see the next
episode of captain america
of i'm sorry the falcon and the winter
soldier
because you may be thinking to yourself
wow tim this show certainly has gotten
woke and these woke media outlets are
certainly pointing out that captain
america is in incel and
uh i must stop you there what we're
actually getting
if you actually watch the story if you
listen to the words of the characters
is criticism of critical race theory and
the woke left
first and foremost the bad guys are
globalists
they're called the flag smashers they
wear masks
they want there to be no borders and
they're willing to hurt innocent people
to get it
that doesn't sound like incels or the
far right baron zemo
who is the anti-hero they break out of
prison he says
she is a supremacist now that she has
this power
you know basically she's going to think
she's the only one so what ends up
happening is
the narrative presented by the rap is
that captain america
is a regular guy who feels inadequate
because these other
super soldiers exist and these super
soldiers are supremacists
who they think they're the best and this
captain america guy in one scene looks
at bucky barnes
and he says it's so easy for you isn't
it with that serum coursing through your
veins
then he gets a hold of the serum and
takes it and becomes a villain
and you know what i see with this
replace super soldier
with white privilege and you get a guy
who doesn't have it who is jealous of
those who do
who will do anything to have it who
looks in the face of bucky barnes and
says it's just so easy for you with your
white privilege
and then you have these far leftists who
believe they're the only ones who can
save everything because they have this
power like the white progressives
and it sounds to me like captain america
represents critical race theory black
lives matter and the woke left
anger angry at those who have the
privilege they
want and they're willing to do anything
to get it because they hate those
they are whiny losers and it's funny
that the rap sees that
and says this guy's an incel no he's a
guy who was
looking at this world of superheroes
that he wasn't a part of
and angry at them for what they had and
wanted it
and said they should they don't deserve
this i'm the real hero sounds to me like
he's criticizing white privilege
would you agree sir uh
that's why i see your point of view that
makes a lot of sense actually
it's very meta and uh pretty interesting
i wonder if the writers were actually
going for like a woke thing because they
did that police thing early on
yeah but i i watched this and when i
first saw zemo say like oh she will be a
supremacist then i was like oh come on
don't go there
like are we really going to do this are
you going to make a thriller about
superheroes turn into a you know
beat you over the head with this
progressive stuff and then i actually
you know
watch through it and now i feel like
they're actually critical of left it's
similar with black panther
black panther was like the left loved it
you saw you've seen black panther yes so
like the left was treating it like this
great
accomplishment you know and it was it
was so amazing but it was actually
politically nuanced it was a a nation
with a literal wall around its borders
refusing immigrants and refugees
versus an ethno supremacist who wanted
to take over the world and supply
a certain race with weapons and i'm like
that's a that's a nuanced political take
i dig it
now we got the falcon and winter soldier
and they're literally doing
what appears to be a mockery of wokeness
i don't know that i mean i i think your
analysis
uh can definitely be
it makes it's reasonable i don't think
the writers
are intending that but i do think that
uh
i think that you probably hit the nail
on the head what if or at least you
you've managed to see something that
that
you know possibly possibly the writers
did not see
i'm not yeah right right so i'm not
entirely sure the writers thought this
all through
but is it possible it's projection like
so much of what the left and the
critical theorists and the workers
what people do they project i want it to
be
um i yeah i i suppose that it that it
you know it is
it is possible because it the it does
make sense
um i imagine they would not be happy
to hear that analysis um but is that
captain america
i you know i mean i'm i'm not a fan of
of you know like i i thought wanda
vision was good
and one division i understand that
they're you know
your criticism of it our criticism of
one division
is legitimate it you know she was the
bad guy first their episodes are trash
not even a real show yeah she's
torturing people yeah and then she's the
good guy yes
that sounds hot or whatever yeah at this
point
it's it's it sounds like these are these
are mini series it's not a it's not
gonna be a recurring season or anything
so it's over already it
may as well have been a movie yeah but
it's so amazing that one division
a lot of people pointed out that it's
like a
let me let me stop here and start over
i've i've heard this meme a lot i don't
know if it's true they said
a male power fantasy is die hard he's
he's climbing
stepping in glass he's got a gun taped
to his back and he's gonna save the day
the guy he's got he's gonna fight back
and defeat the terrorists
and a woman's power fantasy is the
romantic comedy where the woman seems to
bumble about do everything wrong but the
guy ends up falling for her anyway
so you look at wand division and it
feels like it fits more of the
traditional female archetype
that she's angry she's mad at everyone
she gets whatever she wants she does
whatever she wants she's torturing
people and
in the end she's still supposed to be
the good guy uh well i mean i'm not sure
if that is the
the female archetype or not but uh it
does probably just an offensive meme
probably just an offensive um but it
does seem like
i mean i suppose that that again that is
a a legitimate
way of looking at it um but i mean
when i was when i said that that i liked
uh one division uh i suppose that i
i mean that i found it entertaining um i
wasn't
uh i didn't find it i didn't find it
offensive i did
you know because because there are
characters that i cared about you know
like
i cared about uh you know vision and i
cared about
uh wanda maximoff i also think that
because the scarlet witch is one of the
most powerful characters
if not the most powerful character in
the marvel universe i think that what
happens to her
matters um certainly far more than
than what happens to to you know the
in-cell captain america
they come up with and so the story is
more compelling because
yeah i this is a completely new
character that i don't much care for
you know and i i've only watched i
watched the first episode and i haven't
really watched the
any other episodes of of uh falcon i'm a
falcon and winter soldier
i had intended to or i do intend to um
but i was going to wait until there were
more
i've got to kind of kind of bored of it
because it feels like
it's like it's it's just too beat here
yeah
the stakes aren't high enough not
enough's happening the characters don't
matter enough
there's not enough high level anything
to it i
i agree about the the characters don't
matter enough like you know vision was a
was an integral character in in you know
from ultron on you know and
same thing with and wanda again being
the most powerful character in the the
marvel universe
means the stakes are higher we'll see if
the get
go broke continues because with this
this article from the wrap whether my my
analysis is correct or not
a lot of people just view it as getting
woke and they're not going to want to
watch it
yeah it's preachy i heard uh uh jeremy
on the quartering talking about
people turning it off and then i think
it was i'm not talking about it as well
you guys
did you talk about overlord dvd too
because i went and listened to his
his video on it he's like the progenitor
of the rumor so i don't know if that's
true or not but it was like
it was it was a way to talk about what
was going on with the show in general so
i mean i'm i'm i'm i'm stoked for
multiverse of madness
what is this doctor strange oh yes and
that that's going to have wanda in it as
well right
yeah see i mean they're characters you
care about
i gave up on it man once
marvel all the marvel crap all the
cartoons it's like
it's like cartoons for adults like all
the cg crap like
it's like they they they all they tend
to have this like invincibility behavior
where they're all like there's no fear
the characters aren't afraid so there's
no like yeah it doesn't feel like uh
this it
you know this this impending like danger
that you feel when with a really good
hero
that's that's afraid for their life and
fighting for their life
and then in the background of it there's
just all this cartoon stuff going on
in the guys of like cg explosions that
are fake ships that are fake
lasers that aren't real and it's like
man i play video games for i want to be
interactive if i'm going to be having
that sort of
cartoon but we did we did get a really
important point someone just brought up
in the super chat that i just saw
there's a scene before the cop pulls up
and you and
while they're arguing and salmon and
winter sol and bucky are walking and
some little kid goes yo it's black
falcon and he goes
i'm just a falcon and he's like you're
black [ __ ] he's like
nah like and that was some you know so
so this is b young mentioning
isn't that anti welcome like i remember
that it didn't get as much play among
the the you know the the the you know
commentators
and it was legit i'm just falcon and he
is just falcon
dude i think anthony mackie kills and i
think falcon's an awesome character i
i'm stoked for you know i was excited
for the show i just feel like it's not
you know
he got beat up by a tic tac i mean that
was great
i thought that was awesome i like the
character he's cool he's like a military
guy who got this experimental suit it's
legit i think he could have done
like they could have had a better like
introduction form whatever but i'm
stoked
i really liked that when he was like i'm
just the falcon that's right they're
making that point
and i'll add something else too because
i've been watching a lot of star trek
the next generation i've seen them all a
million times and watch them again
today's episode blew my mind i'm
watching it on the bbc it's like 4pm or
whatever
it's the one where uh dwarfs on
alexander comes back from the future
to try and teach himself how to be a
warrior and
there's a point where they don't know
it's his future self and he's telling
this uh you know this this kid who's
like you know 10 years old
no one on the federation starship thinks
of you as a human
because you look like a klingon and he's
like and this kid he goes that doesn't
matter goes yes it does
what you look like does matter and i'm
like that's amazing that starts with the
next generation
way back then was anti-woke was critical
of this idea that being judged based on
how you look
mattered and it was like this guy who
was wrong was telling the kid you have
to
you have to leave and be with your own
kind and i'm like they were actually
being critical of the racists
and now it's come full circle and
they're being critical of the left yeah
that i mean that's that's that was that
was you know
that's what the the the
dream of of dr king was you know where
people
were respected for their own humanity
and that was i heard jim
james lindsay talking about this that
during the civil rights movement
you didn't see uh you know
african-americans
walking around talking about their
blackness they were holding signs that
said
i am a man. and i remember that yeah
you know you know it was an appeal to
their humanity it's like look
i'm a person just like you and and
that's i think that that
that seeing the individual is the is the
important way to view people's not
seeing the group that they come from and
i remember that famous quote from from
dr king where he said he said i have a
dream
that one day there will be a black
superhero who isn't called black falcon
he's just the falcon yes
dude disney remember that one he said
he said that in selma right marvel
and suit and star wars they trashed it
we watched
uh fantasia 2000 a couple nights ago and
the animation was
flat walt disney was gone the magic of
walt disney the guy who created that
animation style that flowy movement
is dead and you can see that in disney's
art
it's he's gone he's not there to oversee
it and to say what's crap
man that company is just in name only
and that that's money gone wrong you
think money in politics is bad
ryan johnson should be put on trial we
demand reparations for what he did at
yeah yeah he should he should definitely
face uh
yeah i mean i'm trying i'm being i'm
being generous by giving him a trial
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time